What do you mean, what do you say that certain foods are drivers of cancer?
So,
certain foods can be a fuel source for a cancer.
So remember, a cancer is regardless of what causes the cancer.
Regardless of what type of cancer
there are certain foods that can be a fuel source of that cancer.
And that can change dramatically.
So, let's say, let's say,
let's say dairy is a fuel source of my cancer and I stay off of dairy.
Well, then let's say the cancer starts feeding more aggressively
through the glycolysis cycle and is feeding more off of sugar.
Oh, then if I retest that and if that tests that way,
then I have to change my diet a little bit and go more off of carbohydrates
and not be juicy, let's say.
And then I'm eating, of course, you still have to eat.
So you're eating more meat.
And then it could change in my fuel source of that cancer is mainly through amino acids,
through meat products.
And then I might have to change my diet again.
So a driver is just where the cancer is getting its fuel source right now.
And again, that can change.
So that's why we suggest getting re-checked.